ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
IT'S JULY TENTH -- NOTING THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND START.
AS A SUB COMMITTEE I AC -- I SAW
MR WAS -- TO HERE HERE MISTER
WEST AS CONCERT WITH SB TWO OH
EIGHT WHEN WE GET EIGHTY AT A
QUORUM AND ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION TO THE ANALYSIS THAT
MAKES REFERENCE TO THE BILL
DEADLINE AS JULY FIRST JUST
WANTED A CORRECT THAT -- THE
BILL THIS JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND JUST
WANTED RIGHT I KNOW THAT'S
PROBABLY A TYPO BUT IT'S ONE
RECALL THAT IT TO ANYONE'S
ATTENTION THAT MIGHT BE CONFUSED
BY THAT.
BUT THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB TWO WAY TO
PER -- CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL.
AIMED AT PREVENTING A ROBO CALL
SCAMS WHICH ARE USED TO DEFRAUD
PEOPLE OF THEIR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND ANYTHING ELSE --
INCLUDING -- THERE -- PEOPLE'S
ID'S UP PEOPLE'S AYE
IDENTIFICATIONS.
I'M PERSONAL INFORMATION.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THE BILL HAS NECK WILL
NEGLIGIBLE COST IF ANY. TO THE
STATE HOWEVER IT COULD PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS.
THIS BILL SET TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DEADLINE FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS. TO
IMPLEMENT CALL RIGHT THAT
AUTHENTICATION MEASURES WHICH
CAN HELP IDENTIFY ILLEGAL
ROBOCALLS AND PREVENT CONSUMERS
FROM BEING SCAMMED.
THIS BILL DOES NOT.
EXPENSIVE UC'S AUTHORITY AND
NARROWLY ALLOWS THE CPC TO WORK
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TICKET TAKE ACTION AGAINST LEGAL
WROBEL COLORS IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE CALL BLOCKING.
I WOULD NOT RESULT IN REAL CALLS
BEING BLOCKED IT DOES NOT CREATE
SIGNIFICANT.
NEW LIABILITIES FOR TELECOMS WE
RECENTLY ADDED SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSED
CONCERNS OF TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS.
AND I WANT TO THANK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAFF IN WORKING
WITH US AND IN A LONG
[inaudible]
THAT SAID.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE AS SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND FINANCE ALL.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME ASSURE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DO
NOT A FILE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT I SEE NO QUESTIONS AND
WE WILL TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR WAS SOME.
AND MISTER ROCK.
LOOKS LIKE YOUR NEXT.
I I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE ONLY
PRESENTING ON SB THREE OF SEVEN
IT WILL ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AS SOON AS WE GET
A FORM YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MEMBERS
AS YOU KNOW THE BILL PERTAINS TO
A LARGE A LARGE WATER PROJECT IN
THE MOJAVE DESERT.
WITH REGARD TO WHICH THE PROJECT
PROPONENT PROPOSES.
TO PUMP AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER PER
YEAR FROM THE AQUIFER.
DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PUMPING
PROPOSED IN A VERY SERIOUS
CONFLICT.
IN THE SCIENTIFIC -- INFORMATION
SURROUNDING THE PROJECT BOTH PRO
AND CON.
THIS BILL HITS THE PAUSE BUTTON
ON THE PROJECT TO ALLOW THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION WORKING
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO REVIEW AND RECONCILE
THE SCIENCE INVOLVED SO THAT AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PUMPING RIGHT MAYBE ESTABLISHED.
SINCE THIS IS A FISCAL NOT A
POLICY COMMITTEE I NOTED AS YOUR
ANALYSIS REFLECTS.
THAT ALLSTATE COSTS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE MINOR ABSORB
MOBILE.
OR REIMBURSABLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT.
APPRECIATE THAT SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY DID.
HE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
I GOT A QUICK SOUND JUST A
REMINDER THAT -- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU'RE
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY TO TO WITNESSES AT TWO
MINUTES -- AND TO PLEASE KEEP
THE ISSUES TO FISCAL MATTERS
ONLY.
YOU MAY THINK.
THANK YOU -- GERMANS ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- NEIL
THE SIDE WITH THE NATIONAL PARKS
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB THREE OH SEVEN WHICH WILL
PROTECT THE TREASURE THAT --
CALIFORNIANS LOVE OUR MOJAVE
DESERT -- WE SEE THE MOJAVE
DESERT AS AN ASSET WORTHY OF
CONTINUED INVESTMENT AND LET'S
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE --
MIGHT BE RELATED ISSUES.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE THESE
DESERT PARK'S GENERATED FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT.
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES CREATED
OVER FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
SUSTAINABLE PERMANENT JOBS --
AND OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR
INCOMES THIS ECONOMY HAS GROWN
OVER THE YEARS -- BUT YOU CAN
ONLY GROWING EVEN IT CAN ONLY
EXIST IF THE WATER AND LAND
RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
THESE BUSINESSES THESE FAMILIES
THESE JOBS HAVE BEEN HUNG OUT TO
DRY BY THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION.
WHICH HAS MIRACULOUSLY DECIDED
TO REMOVE -- ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
REQUIRED FOR THE KIDDIES WATER
PROJECT -- BUT THEY'RE ALSO
THINGS EIGHT ARE YOU CAN'T PUT A
PRICE TAG ON BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
PRICELESS.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THIS
REGION AND THE DESERT SPRINGS.
ARE SACRED TO NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES.
WHO HAVE USED THESE PLACES FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS FOR
TRADITIONAL PRACTICES AND
CEREMONY AND PRAYER?
SO EVERYTHING I MENTIONED WE
STAND TO LOSE IF WE DON'T GET
THIS RIGHT AND IF WE DO NOT ACT.
NOW AND WHEN THERE IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER COSTING US BILLIONS
WHO'S IN THE PICK UP THE TAB
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GONNA BE COULD
EASE.
ANSWER SURE THE STATE DOESN'T
WANT TO PICK THAT UP.
SO THANK YOU SENATOR OUGHT --
THIS BILL INTRODUCES.
SCIENCE BASED DECISION MAKING I
WOULD CLOSE WHICH IS SAYING THAT
IN THESE -- CHALLENGING TIMES --
WE CAN LOOK TO THE WORD I'VE NAY
THIN ONE YEAH EIGHT MICHAEL AND
SEAN WHO ARE SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW TOGETHER FORM THE R. AND B.
GROUP.
BOYS TO MEN AND POLITICALLY SIDE
LET'S NOT WAIT TILL THE WATER
RUNS DRY SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
AND SUPPORT ALSO WANTED TO
CONVEY THE SUPPORT OF AND OUR DC.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN AUTUMN
ON CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST ON SUPPORT BRENT
AND ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
ERICA MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DO IS THERE NO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION ARE THAT'S OKAY WITH
ME BUT IF YOU GUYS DON'T HURRY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON SORRY TWO
MINUTES ON THE PHYSICAL MATTER
HOPEFULLY ONLY.
SO I MET HIM TERROR -- BUT I'M
SURE MEMBERS JOE L<c.cyan>G</c>
REPRESENTING KIDDIES OF THEM.
YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
SPECIFICALLY SPELLS OUT WHAT OUR
CONCERNS ARE.
FIRST WITH US THAT.
OF THE TERM THAT THE BILL USE
RATHER THAN FINDING IS
DETERMINATION.
ARE INTEREST IN THAT IS TWO
THINGS ONE MAKING SURE THAT THE
PROCESS THAT THE COMMISSION USES
IS.
TRANSPARENT ACTUALLY HAS PUBLIC
HEARINGS.
AND SECONDLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
IN FACT THERE'S A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE AGES WHO
WERE VIEW OF THE DETERMINATION
MADE.
AS POINTED OUT YOUR ANALYSIS THE
AUTHOR HAS TO OF THAT THEY THINK
IN FACT THE THE TERMS FINDING
AND DETERMINATION ARE
INTERCHANGEABLE.
OF IF THAT'S INTO THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMAND HOUSES POINTS THAT
OUT -- I JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT
CONCERN ABOUT TRANSPARENCY --
SECONDLY RELATIVE TO TIMING --
THE BILL RIGHT NOW REQUIRES OR
ALLOWS THE COMMISSION UP TO TWO
YEARS TO DO THE REVIEW OF THE
SCIENCE.
SINCE THIS IS IMPACT JUST A
REVIEW OF THE SCIENCE OF
RECONCILIATION AND NOT A BRAND
NEW DEVELOPMENT OF SCIENCE.
WE THINK THAT A PERIOD OF A YEAR
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR THE
COMMISSION TO DO THIS -- TWO
YEARS WITH EXIST IT'S NOT
NECESSARY.
OF FINALLY.
WE HAD SUGGESTED -- AS AN
AMENDMENT THAT THE COMMISSION.
IN THEIR DETERMINATION ACTUALLY
BE ABLE -- TO ESTABLISH WHAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT IS THE GOAL OF THE
BILL SO THAT THERE WOULD IN FACT
BE.
ESTABLISHED A SUSTAINABLE
PUMPING RATE FOR THE PROJECT.
OF THAT WAS OUR OUR WHOLE INTENT
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL
ALIGNED WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENT.
SO THE COMMISSION IN THEIR
DETERMINATION WOULD DETERMINE
THE SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RATE.
OF WHICH WE THINK THAT'S FAIR WE
THINK IT'S IN LINE WITH THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION.
GREGORY FOSTER REPRESENTING
PARTNERSHIP FOR JOBS AND THE AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND A
STRONG OPPOSITION IN REGARDS
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AND JOB
KILLING BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OUT OF TERROR
KRISTIN OLSON HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION AND THE INLAND EMPIRE
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP IN
OPPOSITION.
ELLERY NEAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE NOT
POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROSANNA KARACHI HERE BE
OFF OF THE CALIFORNIA GRONER
COALITION THE GROUND WATER
RESOURCES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE TIE WATER DISTRICT IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN A STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
CHRIS CAR REPRESENT THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
I JERRY TATE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I'M BEFORE WE GOT AN
APARTMENT FINANCE OF IT'S OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO GO HEAD ESTABLISH
A QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
CALDERON CARRILLO.
CHAO.
DEEP EGGMAN.
FONG GABRIEL.
GARCIA MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
RIVAS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE
POSITION NO FILE.
I BILL.
OUT WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR
QUIRK.
AND IN A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
AND I THINK MISTER FUNG HAD A
QUESTION TO MR PEROT.
OF CENTER ROTH IF HE MAY JUST I
HAVE TWO QUICK QUESTIONS MAYBE
CAN DRESS HE REVIEW IN THE COST
OF THE BILL WHAT IS THE
ESTIMATED REIMBURSEMENT AMOUNT
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION LAST.
FOUR IT WILL BE A REIMBURSEMENT
ALSO COVER THE COST OF THE STAFF --
FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING
TO PARTICIPATE PROCESS
[inaudible]
BUSTS OF BY THE BY THE
REIMBURSED BY THE APPLICANT IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE KIDDIES.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE FOR THE COSTS BUT THE
ISSUE NO UNDER THE THE CODE
SECTION INVOLVED WHICH IS -- THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE AMONG
OTHERS SIXTY TWO EIGHTEEN ALLOWS
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO
RECOVER COSTS OF SERVICES AND SO --
WE ANTICIPATE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND ANY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OF THE
CONSULTATION BY -- DID OF YOU
ARE IN PART IN FISH AND WILDLIFE
WILL BE FULLY REIMBURSED.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BROWN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CENTER THIS UP PROJECT IS
CLOSE TO MY HEART THE LEAD
AGENCY IN SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT IN MY IN MY AREA -- WE
LOOK AT SEA QUEST THE GOLD
STANDARD IN THOSE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS
COMPLETED TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THE TRIAL COURT UPHELD IN
FOURTEEN THE APPEALS COURT
UPHELD IN SIXTEEN WHAT WERE YOU
HOPING THAT STATE LANDS IS GONNA
FIND IN IT DID DID THE SEQUEL
PROCESS MISS ANYTHING.
WELL THE AS YOU KNOW SEEK WAS OF
IS A PUBLIC DISCLOSURE STATUTES.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS NOTHING MORE
NOTHING LESS IT'S A PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE STATUS THAT YOU TO
NOTIFY THE PUBLIC.
OF A PARTICULAR PROJECT IT'S
PROPOSED. TO IDENTIFY PARTICULAR
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES TO ATTEMPT
TO IDENTIFY THE MITIGATION FOR
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
SEE QUIRK DOES NOT PERMIT COURTS
AT ANY LEVEL. TO RECONCILE
DIFFERENCES IN SCIENCE THAT ARE
PRESENTED IN THE ER IN FACT THE
COURT IS REQUIRED. TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE OUR DOCUMENT THE
FINAL DOCUMENT.
AND IF THERE IS ANY EVIDENCE.
IN THE DOCUMENT TO SUBSTANTIATE
TO CONSERVE TO SUPPORT THE
CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY THE LEAD
AGENCY.
THE COURT CLOSES THE BOOK AT
THAT POINT AND IN FACT IN COULD
DISS OWN APPELLATE DECISION.
PERMISSION TO READ THECOURT
SAYS IN REVIEWING THE LEAD
AGENCIES ACTIONS UNDERSEA QUOTE
WE MAY NOT SET ASIDE AND
AGENCIES APPROVAL OF ANY -- ARE
ON THE GROUND THAT AN OPPOSITE
CONCLUSION WOULD HAVE BEEN
EQUALLY OR MORE REASONABLE.
SO THERE HAVE BEEN MANY SEQUEL
CHALLENGES -- I THOUGHT FIVE OR
SIXTY ANALYSIS RECITE -- SEVEN
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW I I KNOW SOME
OF THEM AND I HAVE IN MY NOTES
WHAT THE ISSUES WERE THAT THE
COURT CONSIDERS IN THOSE.
IN THOSE SEEK WITH CHALLENGES
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT AT NO
TIME AND NO AND NONE OF THE
TWELVE FIVE SIX OR TWELVE
DECISIONS.
DID THE COURT ATTEMPT TO
RECONCILE THE VERY VERY SERIOUS
CONFLICTS IN THE SCIENCE IN THIS
CASE.
I GUESS MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
THAT IF YOUR BILL GET SIGNED
INTO LAW NOW WILL BE A DECADE
AFTER THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT
IT SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME.
AND YOU KNOW MY WATER DISTRICTS
ARE ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF IN
THE BUILDING RESERVOIRS I'M A
PUBLIC THE CELL PLANET TO HE
BEACH IN IT AT EVERY STEP IT
SEEMS LIKE THE STATE GETS IN AND
LAYS THESE PROJECTS.
I MEAN IF WE GOT KIDDIES IN THE
DSL PLAN IN MIND WE COULD BE
SELF SUFFICIENT IN MY AREA YOU
SAW THE EARTHQUAKES IN.
IN RIDGECREST IN PLACES LIKE
THAT AND THESE PROJECTS ARE
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR AREA
AND YOU KNOW I HOPE YOU WOULD --
YOU KNOW CONSIDER SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE THE
COMPANIES ASK AND JUST NOT MEAN
THE LOCAL CONTROL ISSUES IS MY
BIGGEST CONCERN.
OVER BELIEVE ME IF I MAY VENTURE.
I AM IN I LIVE IN SOMETHING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF WATER AND I IN NO
WAY IN MY AGAINST PUMPING.
WATER FROM THAT -- KIDDIES
AQUIFER WE JUST HAVE TO
ESTABLISH A SUSTAINABLE PUMPING
RATE AND DO IT RIGHT.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS
ANALYSIS IS REVIEW AND
RECONCILIATIONS NOT DONE IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE IN THE ER AND THE
PROBABLY MANY REASONS FOR THAT --
IN MOST CASES IT IS BY THE LEAD
AGENCY AND AND AND THE
RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES INVOLVED
BUT NOT UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS
CASE AND IT'S A SHAME IT WASN'T
DONE -- YEARS IF NOT DECADES AGO
SO THAT IN FACT WATER AT A
SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RATE COULD
BE PUMPING INTO YOUR DISTRICT
TODAY.
THAT'S THE GOAL AND THAT'S
THAT'S MY ONLY GOAL HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER OUTWARD AND
TAKE OUT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
I HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS -- AND
THAT GETS OUT ON OF THE ROLL
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON A
SENATOR WEST AS SB TWO ZERO
EIGHT AND MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK.
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
I WANT -- TO ALERT THE TWO
REMAINING AUTHORS MISS LEYVA AND
MISTER MCCARTY THAT WE ARE GOING
TO RUN THROUGH THIS IF YOU'RE
NOT HERE -- IT'S NOT AN GOOD.
THANK.
YOU WE'LL SEE YOU IN AUGUST --
AT THIS POINT I WILL AND HAVE
MEANT SECRETARY READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SB ONE TWENTY NINE TO FIFTY NINE
TO SEVENTY ONE THREE EIGHTY NINE
THREE NINETY ONE FOR THIRTY SIX
FOUR NINETY SIX FIVE SEVENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE AND SEVENTY ONE THE
MOTION CONSENT CALENDAR.
I MADE BY MR QUIRK AND SECOND BY
MISTER CALDERON THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
AT THIS TIME I'M GOING TO HAVE
AN SECRETARY READ THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE.
SB 314-611-32220 827-632-9330
1-340-639-4264 SEVENTY ONE BY
SEVENTY FIVE FIVE EIGHTY NINE
SIX TWENTY AT SEVEN FORTY NINE
THANK YOU THOSE -- BILLS HAVE
BEEN DISPENSED WITH IF YOU HAVE
COME TO TESTIFY OR REGISTER
RATHER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON EVEN THOSE BILLS
WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO DO SO AT
THE MICROPHONE.
I WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR --
THIS IS SOMETHING WE OFFER BUT
DON'T HAVE -- TO AND AND WE ARE
VERY BAD.
RULES ORIENTED IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND WE WILL HAVE YOU STATE YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER MISS LEYVA PRESENTS HER
BILL.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS KOREA.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MADAM CHAIR ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR A BRIEF PRESENTATION.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
OKAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I THINK THAT'S GREAT
OKAY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION I WAS
SUPPORT OF FREE TOWARD THEM HAVE
A SEAT YOU WANT TO ONE OR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEVE WEBER CALIFORNIA ASKED ME
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
CATHERINE OFTEN SCOTT -- WE
RECOGNIZE WITH CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION WE RECOGNIZE THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL HOWEVER
WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS RELATED.
TO INTERPRETATION OF THE
DISCRETION THAT CAN BE PROVIDED
TO CV PH AND THEN RESULTING IN A
A STILL SIGNIFICANT FIND THAT
COULD -- CREATE COSTS FOR
HOSPITALS SO WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION CONNIE
DELGADO ON WE HAVE TO DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP CAMP.
FORUM IN OPPOSITION.
KAREN SARKISIAN WILL CAL CHAMBER
AND OPPOSE.
ARE THERE -- IN FINANCE
[inaudible]
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MISTER DE UP NOT VOTING IN.
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU I HAD A
AND COURAGE MISTER MCCARTY TO
COME PRESENT ON A CA SIX IF HE
IS IN THE BUILDING.
I WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
HOWEVER IF MISTER MCCARTY SHOWS
UP WE WILL TAKE A BREAK FROM
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ALLOW HIM TO
PRESENT HIS BILL -- IF THERE ARE
MULTIPLE PEOPLE ON THE SAME BILL
WHICH I ASSUME THERE IS AT LEAST --
ONE YOU MAY HAVE TO PEOPLE SPEAK
FOR TWO MINUTES -- ONLY TO THE
FISCAL CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL --
AND THEN AFTER THAT WE JUST YOU
CAN REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT BY
SAYING YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU BELONG TO
ONE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL.
WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO SPEAK ON
PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
TWENTY MY NAME IS DENISE A LOT
OF OTHER PRO LIKE THE NONPROFIT
CALIFORNIA AND I REPRESENT
LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM.
CESAR CHAVEZ SAID HISTORY WILL
JUDGE SOCIETIES AND GOVERNMENTS
BY HOW EFFECTIVELY THEY RESPOND
TO THE NEEDS OF THE POOR AND
HELPLESS.
MY MOTHER WORKED ALONGSIDE CESAR
CHAVEZ AND THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION SHE BELIEVED IN
THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THIS BILL
IS NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF WHO WE
ARE AS A WHAT BILL YOU'RE HERE
ON SB TWO SEVEN SIX AND YOUR IN
SUPPORT.
OF OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX IS AN EXTREMELY
COSTLY BILL THAT ATTACKS IMMUNO
COMPROMISED CHILDREN WELL THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ASSIGNED A LOWER
COST TO THE BILL RESPECTFULLY IS
A GROSS UNDERSTATEMENT.
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THE TERM
THAT SB TWO SEVEN SIX WOULD COST
TEN MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THIS WAS BEFORE THE AUTHOR MADE
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD.
MAKE THE BILL FAR MORE EXPENSIVE
TO JUSTIFY ITS PRICE TAG SB TWO
SEVEN SIX IS BEING PRESENTED AS
A MEANS TO STOP OUTBREAKS AND TO
PROTECT IMMUNO COMPROMISED
PERSONS.
IT WON'T DO EITHER REALISTICALLY
THIS BILL WILL COST AN ACCESS A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ITS
FIRST YEAR AND MORE THAN THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND EACH
SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
THIS DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
COST OF LAWSUITS WHEN CHILDREN
ARE VACCINATED CANCER DOCTORS
BETTER JUDGMENT AND SUFFER
INJURY.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA WE ARE A
SANCTUARY CITY STATE WE DO NOT
DEMONIZED CHILDREN CAN WE REALLY
JUSTIFY THE EXCESSIVE COSTS OF
THIS BILL WITH NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANY OF THE MEASLES CASES ARE
HAPPENING WITH KIDS WITH A
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WILL BE SPENT TO IMPLEMENT TWO
SEVEN SIX BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
OTHER COST SB TWO SEVEN SIX WILL
KICK OUT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL DAY CARE.
WE'VE COUNTLESS OTHERS AT RISK
FOR INJURY AND COURSE VIOLATION
OF THE PRIVACY RIGHTS.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX FORCES
CALIFORNIA TO COMPROMISE ITS
VALUES CALIFORNIA IS INCLUSIVE
PROTECTIVE EMPOWERING SB TWO
SEVEN SIX AS NONE OF THOSE
THINGS WE CAN DO BETTER THAN
THIS.
OUR KIDS DESERVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY THE ALL CALIFORNIANS
ENJOY PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL ASSET EACH OF YOU MAKE THE
TIME TO MEET WITH MEMBERS OF
LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
I WILL LIKE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ
PERMISSION TO REPEAT HIS
TESTIMONY IN SPANISH FOR NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING CALIFORNIANS I
I NO ACTIVE YOU COULD HAVE DONE
IT THE OTHER WAY AROUND -- IF
YOU SPEAK SPANISH WERE HAPPY --
TO TRANSLATED INTO ENGLISH BUT
IT DOESN'T GO BOTH WAYS -- WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A PAUSE ON
TESTIMONY WERE TAKE A PAUSE AND
HAS MY BECAUSE WHAT I SAW THAT
AN AUTHOR CAME IN.
I THINK I SEE HAS HAD -- MISS
MCCARTY REPRESENT ON AC.
EIGHTY SIX IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
[inaudible]
MISS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU THIS IS A A CA SIX
IT'S A MEASURE THAT GIVES THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA THE CHANCE
TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO ALLOW.
IN CALIFORNIA THE RIGHT TO VOTE
AFTER INCARCERATION CURRENT LAW
IS CONFUSING AND UNCLEAR THIS IS
TIME -- TO RIGHT THIS WRONG LIKE
MANY STATES ACROSS THE NATION
HAVE DONE.
AND THIS WILL HELP REINTEGRATE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
BRING BACK VOTING RIGHTS FOR
EVERYBODY WITH ME.
IS REPRESENTED FROM THE ACLU
ENTER SECRETARY STATE.
THANK YOU.
GIVE ME MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY STATE ALEX TO DO WE
ARE IN SUPPORT AND HAVE NO --
HAVE ONLY OBSERVABLE COSTS ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
MY ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
ATTACHMENTS ARE BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EDITION OF SUPPORTERS
SEEN ON ART.
ARE WE RUN INTO SUPPORT HERE --
ANDREW MUSICIAN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AS FUNDING IS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION A CO
SPONSOR IMPOSSIBLE THANK YOU.
OKAY ONE ON BEHALF OF SECURE
DEMOCRACY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS SEE NINE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION
AT THIS TIME -- SECRETARY OF
STATE HAD ANTICIPATED ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RELATED
MEASURE.
AB -- SIX FORTY SIX ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO PLACE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARDS T IMPLEMENT
THIS MEASURE.
AND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
MAKE NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
VOEPEL SYSTEM -- THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS.
THANK YOU I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
AND THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY THE
REASON THAT THE ACA'S WE ARE
DISPENSING A NUMBER THE ACA'S
WITHOUT SENDING THE SUSPENSE.
IS BECAUSE A RULES COMMITTEE WAS
A LITTLE SLOWER AND GETTING THEM
OUT TO US AND WE WANT PARITY
WITH THE SENATE WHO ARE HE HAD
DISPENSED OF FOR ACA'S.
SO THAT IS THE REASON THAT WE
ARE NOT SENDING THIS TO SUSPENSE
IT'S HIGHLY UNUSUAL BUT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR AT TIME RELATED --
EQUALITY WITH THE SENATE SO I'M
WITH THAT I AM PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
NO THANK YOU JUST CLARIFY A
JOINT AUTHORED A JOINT AUTHORED
THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU SB RIVA.
YOU GOT IT THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL -- WITH MISTER DF NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU AT THIS POINT WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT THAT ACTUALLY
CONCLUDES ALL THE ORDER BUSINESS
WE'LL GET YOU BACK TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THERE WAS ONE SPEAKER IN SUPPORT --
IN OPPOSITION I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT SB -- TWO SEVENTY SIX AS
WELL FOR TWO MINUTES IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SPANISH FOR TWO
MINUTES THAT'S FINE TOO BUT ONE
MORE SPEAKER I CAN SPEAK.
ON THE FISCAL MATTER FOR TWO
MINUTES RIGHT NOW BEFORE I START
MY TIME CAN I GET SOME
CLARIFICATION.
A FIVE IF I SEE THE STATEMENT IN
ENGLISH.
ELECTIONS THAT'S WHAT WE DO IS
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE
COMING O TESTIFY WHO CAN ONLY
SPEAK IN SPANISH WE WILL
TRANSLATE FOR THEM I'M SORRY YOU
SEE THERE'S A LONG LINE AND
THEY'RE A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON
SO WE'RE GOING TO KEEP YOUR TEST
NINETY TWO MINUTES.
YOU CAN DO IN EITHER ENGLISH OR
SPANISH SINCE YOU OBVIOUSLY.
OKAY WERE YOU TRANSLATE IN
SPANISH IF I SAY THAT.
IN ENGLISH ARE YOU WANT ME TO
TRANSLATE SPANISH I'D BE HAPPY.
I CAN TRANSFER.
YOU CAN SECURE YOUR USING YOUR
TIME NOW SO YOU'RE THIRTY
SECONDS AND YOU CAN SPEAK FOR
TWO MINUTES.
I DO NOT PLAY ALRIGHT WE HAVE.
HERE WE HAVE ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE NOW FIFTY SECONDS INTO
TWO MINUTES YOU CAN SPEAK IN
ENGLISH OR SPANISH.
NOT GOING TO LET THE NOTABLE
YOUR SITE IN A CALIFORNIA OR NEW
YORK YOUR PERCENT TOTAL AT THE
MOST POLITELY BUT THEN MAYBE GOT.
SENATE CHAVEZ EQUALLY STORY
WHO'S GOT OUT ALSO SEE THAT IS
IT WAS WILL BE AT MOST PROLIFIC
GOT SICK WHEN I COULD GET THIS
ONE DONE.
I LOVE THIS SIZE AND WAS BALD AS
HE LEADS EVEN IF ANSEL'S ME
MOTHER THE WHOLE BOTH A TRAVIS
AND SEE.
THAT THE HOLIDAYS ARE THE
COOLEST WHEN EVILS EXACTLY -- IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA BUT
APPLE'S IT'S A PREFERRED ALAIN
ORDER BUT THEN THE US COULD GIVE
US SOME OF CALIFORNIANS.
AS THE BEST A VERY THIS AT SOME
POINT BUT I LAY EXPERIMENT I
MEANT THE COST DOES LOOK AT THAT
KIND OF PERSON I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE DESK AND THEN
MISSILES NINOS.
CB UNETHICAL MEET THERE I SEE I
SEE NOVEL ACOSTA MAY NOT AFFECT
WHAT IS WITH WILL SUMMON FIT AS
OWNERS OF THE MISS YOUNG BROTHA.
IT.
IS THE FANTASY GET AUTHORITY OF
ART IS ONLY BECAUSE UNITS GAS
AND AND PARTICULARLY SO SAM
WHICH I MUST GOT ABOUT A WHOLE
CITY COUNCIL PLACE YOU'LL.
SEE PRESENT THE COMMON MENU BUT
AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL OF PRO YET
NO SKAGGS INSTANCE MAYBE CLASS.
SIGNIFY THE ENTRY INTO THE MEAL
SIMPLE THEM JANA'S OF ARTISTS
BUT I INCLEMENT THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM THEY FACE
IT'LL GET POSSIBLE ALSO IT'LL
SCHOOL FORCE.
ESTIMATES THE BASES IT WAS
AROUND WITH WAS THE NORTH MUST
WILL AND I WAS A LIST WHEN I
EVEN I WANT ANY OTHER HAD I'M
WHICH IS WHAT THIS PERSON AS
ANGRY AS WELL AS A FREELANCE
YANIS.
BEFORE SAID I LOVE YOU LESSEN
THIS VIGILS THE PENINSULA.
GLASS YES THANK YOU AND I I WENT
AHEAD AND LET YOU GO.
FOR AND I APPRECIATE -- SPIRIT
OF WHICH YOU GUYS LET'S NOT
LET'S LET'S KEEP GOING THE
SPIRIT OF WHICH I THINK YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS WERE CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SO I'D.
BE HAPPY TO HELP THEM OUT ON
ENGLISH SB TWO TWO SEVEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA THIS IS A UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD LUCK TODAY THAT PASSED
TODAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT MY NAME IS VANESSA MADRID
AND I AM CO FOUNDER OF LATINOS
FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM -- I AM A
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN.
AND I OPPOSE THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU GUYS YOU'RE GONNA SAY YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION OR WE WILL SHUT DOWN
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU SPOKE ALREADY.
YOU SPOKE ALREADY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DEFINITELY CAUGHT THAT.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE BARR HANA.
I'M WITH LIKE THE NORTH FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM AND I'M ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF EMPOWERING ALL SHADES
OF BROWN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALEJO'S YOU TOO AND I AM HILLS
THANK YOU.
YES I DON'T TO SHOW YOU OFF LIKE
MINE.
YOU KNOW HOW TO FOLLOW RULES
KATIE HUNT TUNE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
CHARITY MILLER ON BEHALF OF ALL
PARENTS WHO CANNOT BE HERE AGAIN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AB IF YOU IF PEOPLE CANNOT SIT
IN THE AUDIENCE NOT SPEAK WE
WILL HAVE A SERGEANTS REMOVE YOU
I'M TRYING TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING UP.
WE WANT. TO BE HAPPY IN LIFE.
OKAY SERGEANT I CAN'T I CAN'T
RUN A MEETING WHEN PEOPLE ARE
YELLING FROM THE AUDIENCE I'M
SORRY.
NAOMI HERE.
I OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU.
DOCTOR KATIE GUINAN AND AYE
OPPOSED SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU.
ERIN ROMERO I REPRESENT LATINOS
FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND I OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVEN SIX AND YOU.
AMBER SAUNDERS STRONGLY OPPOSED.
HI AM SHANNON PRIMARY SPECIAL
NEEDS PARALEGAL AND I'M WITH
EDUCATE ADVOCATE WERE STATE RIDE
GROUP THAT REPRESENTS CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES A MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN.
AND WE FIRMLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS AMBER POWERS I
REPRESENT STILL STANDING WHICH
IS AN ORGANIZATION OF MOTHERS
AND FATHERS TO BURY THEIR
CHILDREN AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS FELICIA WOFFORD AND
I'VE A MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KELLY'S ACTS MOTHER OF TWO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI RHIANNA ALVAREZ FROM FREEDOM
KEEPERS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL GOT BUT THE THANK YOU I'M
JACQUELINE SYKES AND I PROPOSED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KRISTI
DAWES AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE SB
TWO SEVENTY SIX THINKING.
MY NAME IS HOLLY NOT PLAYING I'M
A MOTHER OF ONE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMIE WHITE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STACY BACKGROUND
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS ANGIE MILLENNIALS
CONSTITUENT OF WENDY CARILLO I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE PLEASE VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL IT HURTS MY
CHILD THANK YOU WERE GOING TO
STICK TO OUR NAME OUR
ORGANIZATION OUR POSITION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF MR KEN COOLEY AND
I OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS AMY TAYLOR I'M A
SPECIAL EDUCATOR AND MOTHER OF
TWO THIS WILL AFFECT MY CHILDREN
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO STATE A
ONE WE'RE GOING TO STATE TO YOUR
POSITION.
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
HI MY NAME TWENTY ATLANTA MOTHER
OF THREE CHILDREN FULLY
VACCINATED AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M JEFFREY TAYLOR A STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MAY CAN I AM
A MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FETZER FOUNDER OF
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS
REPRESENTING TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEATHER MILLS FORD
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TARA THORTON MOTHER AND MEMBER
OF OUR KIDS ARE CHOICE A KNIFE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS.
IS MY ANSWER IS NO.
THANK YOU ALLIANCE.
MY NAME IS JOSH WILLCOLEMAN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED THE STUPIDITY.
HI MY NAME IS REALLY NICE FAMILY
POSES BEAR THANK YOU LILY.
LIVIA CAN YOUR ROSEVILLE I
OPPOSE.
I AM MAKE IN MAIL FOR A AND I
OPPOSE THE PALE THING.
HELLO MY NAME IS MADELINE VALDEZ
VASQUEZ MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAURA FRAZIER FROM
STEVENSON RANCH CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND A FORMER
TEACHER AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY RIVAS FAMILIES UNITED
FOR HEALTH MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CARLY BALL THE AND A
PEDIATRIC OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
IN A CONSTITUENT OF DISTRICTS
SIX AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NAOMI STORY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA ANALYST I AM
REPRESENTING LATINOS FOR MEDICAL
FREEDOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS POPPY DARBY
FROM CINEMA AND EYES OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS MONICA MARTINEZ FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WE WILL
NEVER COMPLY.
MY NAME IS NICOLE FROM SILICON
VALLEY I'M A CPA AUDITOR AND
CORPORATE FINANCE PROFESSIONAL
AND THIS BILL WON'T FIX AT OKAY
THANK YOU I OPPOSE THIS THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KAYLA WHILE BEEN.
I'M IN -- JIM WOOD ST STRICT.
FROM YOU CAUGHT.
AND I'M THE MOTHER OF A SPECIAL
CASE.
THANK YOU.
WORK WHERE YOU GUYS THE NAME OUR
ORGANIZATION AND STARK AND I'M
HERE TO OPPOSE MY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES IN GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
MY NAME IS MELISSA ALSOP I
REPRESENT PARENT ADVOCATE LEAGUE
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MIKE MATTINGLY TIME
WITH THE FUNKY FATHER'S CLUB AND
I SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
MAYBE REMEMBER THAT ONE NO DNA
DATABASE YOU PASSED OUT.
LAST YEAR.
I SUPPORT DO NOT SUPPORT THANK
YOU THAT'S BILL IS NOT UP THANK
YOU.
TAKE SHOP TEACHER MOTHER OF ONE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS A NEW BY THE I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER AND A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEALTHY AGAIN I AM AS
A MOTHER OF THIS LITTLE GIRL I
HAVE Q. KIDNEY FAILURE AFTER
EACH PEAVEY BACK THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE THE SALE.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW AYE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE THESE HERE
OKAY LEE -- MY GRANDPARENTS DID
NOT COME PAINTED YELLOW JERRY
THAT THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS TYLER BAGLEY YEAH.
I AM A SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA NINE OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA PERMITS GO I'M
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THING
CAM.
MY NAME IS CAROLINE I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEATHER PINE I'M FROM
MERCED COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
THERESA TRIES HE I'M IN A
PROFESSOR IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN.
AND I REPRESENT ALSO SIX
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED OTHER
CHILDREN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS NICOLE RAFFERTY AND
FROM LAKE ARROWHEAD CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIZ PORTER I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES MOTHER OF THREE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARC MARTEL OR FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA -- STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LAUREN TREMBLAY VACCINE INJURED
MOTHER FROM PINE MOUNTAIN CLUB
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALLISON SIR I'LL I
REPRESENT FAMILIES UNITED FOR
HEALTH LATINOS FOR MEDICAL
FREEDOM AS WELL AS MY SON WHO
WENT INTO ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK I
OPPOSE A SPELL.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA WAGNER I'M
FROM ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA NINE
BEHALF OF THIS SWEET GIRL AND MY
VACCINE INJURED BROTHER WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JASMINE PALOMINO AND
I REPRESENT FAMILY AND LATINOS
BACK HOME AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
US AYE OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS VERONICA CLINTON
AREN'T ON BEHALF OF MY VACCINE
INJURED SON I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SAM NIELSEN I
REPRESENT CENTRAL VALLEY
ADVOCATES FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS AS
LONG AS WELL AS LATINOS FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RACHEL ANDREAS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
HUSBAND WHO IS.
A CURRENT BATTALION CHIEF WE ARE
NOT ANTI VACCINE THIRTY IRAQ
THINK LATER MY DAUGHTER IS YOU
CAN WRITE YOUR POSITION BUT
WE'RE NOT TAKING TESTIMONY AT
THIS POINT.
MY NAME IS RACHEL WILLIAMS AND I
ALSO REPRESENT CENTRAL VALLEY
ADVOCATES FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI I'M KELLY LIKE DELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
ALSO INTERPRETING FOR MY
DAUGHTER WHO'S DEAF.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA VAN HILL
HEART I'M A MOM A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHELSEA LYTLE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SORRY HARSH STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI.
MY NAME IS PEARL UGLY.
AND I'M DEAF MY CHILDREN ARE
DEAF AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JESSE GARRABRANT
CLASSIC COUNTY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S ANGELA HICKS AND
HEAR FROM ORANGE COUNTY
REPRESENTING PARENTS UNITED FOR
KIDS ALSO REPRESENTING.
OVER THREE THOUSAND FAMILIES
THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE FULLERTON FROM
MY BOOK I'M OVER HERE. TWO I I'M
I UNDERSTAND I'M SORRY THERE WAS
A CONCERN THAT WE MISS
SOMEBODY'S TESTIMONY AND I'M
TRYING TO WRITE THAT AS WELL
OKAY.
MY NAME IS JULIE FULLERTON I'M
FROM COSTA MESA CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE TENANT LATINOS
FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM ALSO
PERSONALLY.
FOR FREEDOM.
ALSO JUST WANT TO POINT OUT SOME
NO NO.
NO YOU CAN SUPPORTER POSE THIS
BILL.
YOU CAN OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THEIR OCCUPATION USUALLY.
I I AM LETTING PEOPLE SAY THEIR
MOTHER I'M NOT QUITE LEADING
PEOPLE GOING TO TESTIMONY ABOUT
THEIR THEIR CHILDREN'S MEDICAL
CONDITIONS ARE PERCY MEDICAL
CONDITIONS.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU YOUR
COMPLETE WE ARE NOT HAVING A
DISCUSSION.
THE NEXT NEXT NEXT NEXT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO.
OKAY SO YOU'RE OPPOSE AN AYE
OPPOSED.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DEANNA MARINE I
REPRESENT LATINOS FOR FREE --
MEDICAL FREEDOM AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA JOHNSON
FROM LAGUNA BEACH CALIFORNIA I
DO HAVE A VACCINE INJURED CHILD
EXAMS WRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LESLIE BALANCE WELL
UP FROM OCEANSIDE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SAN DIEGO HERE IN MY
HOUSE LIKE YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AARON DAVIDSON FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I REPRESENT
LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
MY VACCINE INJURED LATINA
SPECIAL NEEDS DAUGHTER.
THANK YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT.
HI -- I'M VANESSA JONES I
REPRESENT A CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
CAROL NELSON FROM BY SO YOU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OF
LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM I
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER TO LUNA GARDEN GROVE
MOTHER OF TWO MEDICALLY EXEMPTS
CHILDREN I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JERRY LYNN FROM VICE A A
CALIFORNIA AND WITHOUT
REPRESENTING.
OF PARENTS UNITED FOR CHILDREN
AND LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK.
AMANDA FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY --
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
TERRA MADSEN MY HUSBAND DAN
MADSEN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
BRIANNA BORDERS FROM ORANGE
COUNTY TO CHILDREN WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THING CAM.
MICHELLE CHILD FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MAKAYLA TROUSER FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I'M A CHARTER STUDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM.
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MARROW FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I
GREATLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THING
CAM.
ERICA MY UNITS FROM RIVERSIDE
PEDIATRIC NURSE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
BERMAN DEATH ON WITH LATINOS FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM.
OPPOSE THIS BILL WILL PUT YOU ON
NOTICE THANK YOU.
WHAT HE SAID?
I'M MY NAME'S MICHELLE MOTHER OF
FIVE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEIDI I REPRESENT
LATINOS FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM IN
YOUR NOTICE.
AND AYE OPPOSED.
HI MY NAME IS VALENTINE AND I
BILLS FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SERRA RULE WITH LATINOS FOR
MEDICAL FRIEDMAN OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I RING GARCIA FROM NOR
CALIFORNIA WITH LATINOS FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM AND IMPERILING
ALL SHE'S A BROWN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME SEE A LIMóN USE I'M
REPRESENTING MY VACCINE INJURED
BROTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I OPPOSE YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME LACKEY LOW.
I AM VERY DELEGATE YOUR TIES TO
NATIVE AMERICAN VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS SHOULD PUT YOU IN
CONTACT OF INTERESTING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
POSITION.
MY NAME IS AN A PLUS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JULIET APPEARS.
I'M A NURSE AND I REPRESENT THE
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY IN
O'NEAL'S CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THEY DIDN'T CARE
SAID I OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND REPRESENT LATINOS
FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND I OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY
WHAT IS YOUR NAME SERENA THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA MAY HE WON'T
FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE STUFF
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A MAKING AND I'M
FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JONATHAN LOCKWOOD
AND I REPRESENT ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T BELIEVE YOU SHOULD BE
MANDATE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL.
ME AND THERE'S ADDITIONAL PEOPLE
IN THE UPSTAIRS ONE MAKE SURE
BUT HE HAS A CHANCE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KIM
CARPENTER I'M FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAX CARPENTER I'M
ALSO FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH FAT.
HOW ARE YOU?
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS MAIL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY I REPRESENT
LATINOS FROM MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CASH RESERVES AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK ON
ITEM THAT HAS BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHERE THE AUTHOR
DID NOT PRESENT.
SEEN NONE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THANK
YOU